[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hello, my name is Ankur Kotwal
and welcome to This Week
in Android Development
for February 17, 2014.
Last week Leon showed us
how to use the Google Cast
SDK for Android,
whilst Katherine
showed us how to connect
to Google Play services
using the GoogleApiClient.
Katherine also put
together a special app
to help you connect
with your valentine,
and this was actually
part of a two-part DevByte
series called "Just For Us."
Todd gave us lesson 3.1 in the
ongoing "Play Games for iOS"
series, where he showed
us how to use leaderboards
to connect with your loved ones.
Fred's "Mystery DevByte"
series has been revealed
and it's on the Media
Router Framework,
so please be sure
to check it out.
And Todd and Wolf are going to
explain turn-based multiplayer
gaming in the latest
episode of "Game On."
For this week in Android
Development, I'm Ankur Kotwal.
Because maybe you're going
to be the one that saves me,
and after all,
you're my wonderwall.